yo welcome to this video a bit of a late
start here and very unlucky start I
think because I have the clear
suspicions but I got something delivered
to me and the doorbell will be ringing
in a couple of seconds so see there it
is yeah I told you see that's awesome
okay that that was 30 seconds down the
drain um yep yeah it's about ever I have
a window thankfully enough in my office
and have a look right out to the street
and we have those very we have those
yellow on yellow painted vents that did
that deliver the things and whenever I
see something yellow the right-hand side
of my vision yeah I know okay then they
deliver stuff to me yep so what is this
he wants to really really play a four
year right hmm ok let's go age 6 it's
not going to give me this Bishop I ok he
did he isn't so just filled chattering
which I wanted to do anyway ok yeah and
King age 70
I probably have to there we go F form
hmm yeah i was thinking c5 just a
checking this on don't want to take i
mean i can't possibly take on d4 that's
interesting now and I want I want I want
to keep a pawn on e5 simply to restrict
the sea to bishop
in case you're wondering about those
deliveries the thing is that quite often
it's not even for me um it's just that
obviously I'm working working from home
so I'm I'm very often the guy that they
that they give them things to be a 44
neighbors they are not at home because
they work in the office or wherever and
I'm at home all the time so I very often
the 12 to take them take the deliveries
um that dissolves a quick quick move
them yeah that's it sets a dangerous
dangerous p sacrifice still it's
difficult not to take it as age 6 is
under that that much pressure hmm yeah I
know it's dangerous but I have to take
it it's not not much choice okay so he
wants to check on g7 so maybe this one
let's see gap it's it's going to be very
dangerous anyway but what can you do I
couldn't really not take it wasn't
possible
I take like we can take with the Queen
what a silly idea I mean on my end of
course ok I can I can I have the check
there then I yes Bishop b3 after the
check
yeah I don't think I can who would this
anyway there was a nice piece sacrifice
their night at five hmm
okay i was thinking i can maybe return
some material but it's not not even that
is probably possible okay let's give the
check now just King edge too probably
so long age seven Queen g5 I have mmm
Queen f6 just about maybe
it's not even difficult to play
unfortunately cannot take these six here
you can get the night to g6 somehow
still losing but now maybe if I can get
the night to g6 somehow can somehow
continue this
Jim maybe I'm some are warning 92 g69 h6
is also pretty good but I can maybe take
and plain ig6 that could hold actually
this Bishop 1 C 2 is not playing maybe
okay it's not it's not great or anything
but might be and this possible to
continue now that is taking time that's
a good sign
hmm I'm not directly checkmated now I
think check okay I have to do this now
this smooth I've got two nights for the
rock climber this is the problem he has
this the active deep on which is not so
easy to take only thing really is really
slow what is he doing here hmm weird
yeah my king is in fact a relatively
safe it's not it's not going to do down
quickly the night is some the
notoriously good defender that it is
supposed to be covering and Queenie 6
check and things like that okay I can
give the check now not sure that it
helps much check for queen of 70 queenie
queenie to is actually an interesting i
just got clean f6 get him let's go let's
go for the check and Queen f7 and then I
can take on the seven next I think I
hope Oh am I only 11 seconds my time
management sometimes it's just so bad
he's taking taking a long time as well
Queen there of course they're armed
Jesus
Queen 10 I'm taking that Chuck forfeits
on time I am for feeding on time I'm 11
from check made what a baby what do
wacky get you I do today what was this
why what what was taking me though so
long yeah I had some seconds it's
basically pre moving here and he really
crave played for herself medium okay it
was just a just a weird game all in all
with the distractions and whatnot but ok
let's let's still have a look there care
went here and he went for this this
piece sacrifice interestingly enough
rook f3 that looks quite normal and this
is an interesting move it definitely is
yeah it's hard to not take it right I
mean he's threatening on age six and
these g7 and so on I have to check you
know look har I don't really know i mean
the computer is giving 000 but this is
not to be trusted those kind of attacks
are often a very deep ear and the
computer-assisted i mean if the computer
is giving compensation this is kind of
yeah making me doubt blacks position ok
the cyst isn't seem to be that great and
she can win now with the bishop cakes
and this is Chavez winning by the engine
yeah yeah probably I'm not completely
sold on Jeff's however is this really a
total win this is given us plus 2 by the
computer
okay that's two pawns I was thinking
that this Bishop this may be so bad that
I have some chances but yeah probably
not check I mean why does much better
anyway check even here due to the deep
on why this much better okay this is not
really working but by now it was very
weird due to the time yeah history has
those ideas like windy six Queens
channel I didn't really find a suitable
defense yeah I just I just didn't see
Quincy seven don't ask me why like 96 is
still interesting yeah yeah it was just
a crapshoot with with the time okay well
thanks for watching